[Music]
it is ordered adjudged and decreed that
Walter McMillian is to face death by
electrocution it's my dad sir sit down
young man John would you sit down they
do nothing wrong please judge hold on
one second I won't say it again
sit down not even you're gonna kill my
dad for no reason
they convicted an innocent man I was
always taught to fight for the people
who need to help me most you don't know
what it is yeah man got hit no evidence
how many of you all were with Walter
that morning you ain't quit miss no sir
we all which I want my son grow knowing
his mom stopped doing what was right
because she was scared I think we could
build a case strong I'll have to bring
him home and I'm not gonna stop until
I've done that present you do it
[Applause]
your life is still meaningful and I'm
gonna do everything possible to keep
definitely taking it we don't do who
he'd love then he wouldn't exist I'm
good
it's like nothing really matters to him
right now
including me you gotta think real hard
about this do you have people that need
you no I'm taking the fight
Victor Drago son of Ivan Drago who
infamously kill Apollo Creed appeared
today to issue a challenge to Adonis
Creed
don't do this I got a choice that's the
same thing your father said you died
right here in my hands
that kid was raised in Haiti
dangerous he protected me that I never
been fished ain't worth it
is not just us anymore of day I want to
rewrite history if you want to fight
this man that's you're busy but don't
pretend this about your father
this here is all about my way
tonight of his hairs it was fine but I
the tribulation
[Music]
this won't be the end of me
are you
they can't because we're a team
[Music]
now you know what you're fighting for
[Music]
Brown after brown you learn more about
yourself when I stepped in hurry it
wasn't all about me I have seen God's
fly I've seen men build weapons that I
couldn't even imagine I've seen aliens
drop from the sky yeah but I have never
seen anything like this
how much more ID
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
my son it is your time
my respected
you get to decide what kind of King you
are going to be
don't please
[Music]
yeah
because we
we
I waited my entire life for this the
world's going to start over I'm a burn
at all what happens now determines what
happens to the rest of the world
have some fun
[Music]
so it's Ellie are you serious miss again
of testosterone you can't invite a girl
to a place like this whoa I'm gonna buzz
really she's not gonna talk about Xbox
I'm gonna be sitting here being like oh
I have to fart but maybe I can't right
now better have some hot friends open
the door
I don't care gettin wasted no I need my
girl broke up with me
wait you Bridget Jones we're going out
you're single or staying single with you
man hey awesome weird mint dude it's cuz
it's a boner pill you got four hours to
drink like Keith Richards still get
funky any action like nothing it's just
harder than you think this is the part
where we go home alone you're sitting on
my coat hmm I was gonna make you wait
too then I realize I'm the dude
we're not supposed to say more than
twice and when we never seen this chit
twice in one day what's the deal with
you and she'll see you doing here anyway
[Music]
what hate doesn't mean what you think it
means
it doesn't Oh what does our relationship
do that wait you guys are in a
relationship
[Music]
I've been trying to pretend that things
haven't changed
hey come here man do not hug me with no
pants on right respect being there for
someone when they need you that's all
relationships are
[Music]
lovely smile I love the way we fit
together in bed because we're the same
height our couches lined up naturally
really good I love that I love that you
come in so we're gonna tow that oh yeah
I'm doing dude
which one of you idiots uses subtenant I
do
why because I thought it was lotion but
now my junk is orange looks like a
traffic cone it looks like a sad giraffe
[Music]
now if any of you guys ever seen one of
these bad things for real we burned
almost every physical book in the
country just by the time you guys grow
up there won't be one book left burn it
[Music]
what's wrong on time your vitals have
been off recently did firemen used to
put out fires that's a classic lie have
you used your drops today I wanna know
why we burn we are not born
we must be made equal by the fire and
then we can be happy I got things and
stopped my head that don't make sense
dreams I can't explain it before the men
come back do you want to know what's
inside these books insanity
you're lying to you aren't you telling
me
[Music]
you never do anything
[Music]
you just like beanie
I'm not like bTW
[Music]
we have an important test for you if
anybody sees me I'm dead the danger is
real and immediate we need to get out of
what if I tell these people what you do
words are a terror sound I know
knowledge is a dangerous thing
you've probably gonna want to get this
on camera
[Music]
I don't want to do it dude I don't want
to do it okay are you ready do it give
me a countdown I will really become my
theory though is that it's like a muscle
watch this is why I think we're getting
stronger you know mister working it out
there's nothing stopping us
[Music]
what did you do that was Ruiz was it an
accident Andrew Andrew worry about
injury listen to me we can't screw
around with this it's too dangerous
hey drew it's not engaged stop this
right now
[Applause]
[Applause]
Steve wait up man look at this
[Music]